eat quick Easter eggs from The Last of
Us episode 4. Ellie's no pun intended
book was given to her by her friend
Riley who hasn't been seen in the show
yet but we do get a glimpse of her in
the trailer The Naughty magazine Ellie
finds is called the bare skin while in
the game it's the not so subtle hard man
the actor who plays Perry is the same
guy who played Tommy in the game the two
movies playing at the cinema in Kansas
City are underworld and Matchstick man
two films that came out in 2003 when the
pandemic hit in both versions Ellie
saves Joel but in the game version she
flat out kills the attacker the rubble
underground hints that were likely to
see a bloater next episode game's rarest
and toughest of the infected this huge
train bridge is actually the world's
longest steel Trestle Bridge found in
Alberta Canada this episode confirms
Tommy was in the military with the
episode one bumper sticker on his truck
showing us he was in the first Armored
Division a real division called The Old
Ironsides for more fun facts check out
my channel think Story on YouTube